bonjour on vous retrouve en direct de
Kiev quels sont les nouvelles du front
oui en ce moment cette bataille concerne
encore plus que ces dernières semaines
les médias Ukrainiens vraiment ça parle
que de ça en ce moment alors que la
ville semble être encerclé en forme de
fer à cheval si vous voulez par les
forces russes une des routes principales
qui mène à bas coût est encore
utilisable par les Ukrainiens peut-être
une autre route secondaire mais ces deux
routes sont sous le feu des Russes
presque constamment c'est ce que disent
l'effort ukrainiennes sur place en tout
cas mais selon mes informations tes
travailleurs humanitaires peuvent encore
se rendre dans la ville des journalistes
de la télévision ukrainienne ils sont
allés avant-hier en tout cas ont pu
constater bien sûr des ruines dont le
centre-ville et puis une situation
extrêmement difficile pour les quelques
milliers de civils qui sont toujours à
backgrout la question se pose de plus en
plus en Ukraine sur la question des
enfants qui sont restés à batmout c'est
le choix de leurs parents de leur garder
sur place et certains parce que les
adultes ont bien le droit de décider de
risquer leur vie alors que il est
clairement extrêmement dangereux de
rester dans cette ville en ce moment
est-ce que les Ukrainiens ne devraient
les enfants
Ukrainiens excusez-moi
ne devrait pas être évacué par la force
mais pour le moment ce n'est pas quelque
chose que la loi ukrainienne ne permet
alors ça c'est une partie du débat une
autre partie du débat on icône en ce
moment sur badmut c'est est-ce que il
faut vraiment continuer à défendre Beck
et ongles cette ville alors que pour
beaucoup son importance et plus
symbolique que stratégique aujourd'hui
la vice-ministre de la Défense en Amalia
a dit dans une interview que c'est bien
les militaires qui prendront la décision
et non pas les politiques mais si il a
dû le dire aussi explicitement c'est
bien que beaucoup de monde pensent que
c'est une décision politique mais cette
valeur symbolique bien sûr pour batmoud
c'est c'est clairement pas à prendre à
la légère puisque ça fait vraiment la
fierté de l'Ukraine que le pays est
réussi à maintenir le contrôle de
batmout malgré cette attaque acharnée de
la part des Russes jusqu'au début du
printemps merci Gulliver crack pour ces
derniers éléments